- You're putting yourself in front
of so many people just by going like,
"I'll give it a shot."
And yeah, it might not work.
And yeah, and when it doesn't work,
some people might be like,
"You, you tried."
Well, them, try again.
Some people get blocked.
Everyone gets a really good idea of like,
"I want to do something."
Sometimes you sit around, watch
a movie, listen to podcasts,
you're like, "I want to
do that," then they stop,
'cause like, "I dunno how,
I don't have the money."
Money is a hurdle that's
kind of easy to get over.
To just hear how simple it is.
Sometimes you just need
somebody to be like,
"It's this simple, dude,"
and give you three steps.
and suddenly you're like, "That's it?
"I can take it the rest of the way."
Getting started is
always the hardest part.
If you're here listening to
me talk about this stuff,
you are not a film fan,
you're a film maker.
You just haven't made a film yet.
Go out and make your film.
- He's an American film maker,
actor, comedian and podcaster.
He rose to prominence for his
low-budget comedy film Clerks,
in which he acted, directed
and co-produced it.
He's also known for his
long, humorous Q&A sessions
which are often filmed and
distributed for DVD release.
He's Kevin Smith, and here's my take
on his top 10 rules of success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite.
And make sure to stick around all the way
to the end for some special bonus clips.
Also, as Kevin is talking,
if he says something
that really resonates
with you, please leave it
in the comments below
and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(dramatic music)
- You can do what's expected, absolutely,
and sometimes you'll have the
expected or hoped for result.
But there's so many doors into this thing,
and I'm not just talking about film,
I'm talking about everything
that you're interested in life.
There are so many doors,
and we all look right at
the front door and go,
"How do we get through,
there's a massive line?"
Go to the back door.
Go to the side window.
Dynamite a hole in the wall.
You belong in the room too,
you don't have to wait to
be invited into something.
You know, I'm here to tell you,
nobody will ever invite
you into something amazing
'cause they're like, "You, it's ours."
So if you want to be involved in something
and you want to see
something that doesn't exist,
all you have to do is try.
You're putting yourself
in front of so many people
just by going like, "I'll give it a shot."
And yeah, it might not work.
And yeah, when it doesn't work,
some people might be like,
"You, you tried."
Well, them, try again.
That's it, man.
That's all we're here to do is try.
Because at the end of this,
there's no winner, we all die.
So just try.
Try, try every day before
they stick you in the grave.
And I'm not talking
about moving mountains,
I'm talking about all that
you sit there and go like,
"I'm going to do that one day."
Do it tomorrow.
Do it right now.
Just give it a shot.
Because maybe it takes a
day, maybe it takes a week,
maybe it takes five years, but
you don't get there without
just giving it that first step.
And I get it, the first step's hard,
they say the journey of a million miles
begins with a single step.
What they don't say is,
single step is harder
than every other mile
that comes after that.
All those miles are easy
once you take that first one,
but I understand how difficult
it is to take the first step.
Look at me, I'm a fat
man, and I read every day,
stop being fat, you're going to die.
And I'm all like, I will, one day.
And I never take that first step, man,
and so I continue to be fat.
But in everything else in life,
I can take that first step.
So, I know what I'm talking about, kids.
Like, try, just give it a shot, man.
Don't worry what say, and I'll
clear the mystery for you,
will say everything, dude.
You can build a cathedral,
and your steeple will break the clouds,
and someone will down below be yelling,
"You're doing it wrong!"
Don't listen to those people.
Life moves forward, man, and
people that want to tell you
you suck are usually behind you.
So, keep moving forward
and try, try everyday.
My first piece of advice, don't
ask anybody for money, man.
I'm looking at the wrong place.
They'll never going to give me the job
if I look at the monitor.
- [Woman] You can look at
me, that's good enough.
- But I was playing to her.
I was trying to make a connection.
HuffPost Live, as they say.
- [Woman] Alright, so you've done it.
Camera one, go for it.
- Don't go to people for money, man.
You don't need that much money,
unless you're making some
kind of underwater epic,
you don't need to go to somebody.
If there are no more gatekeepers,
I mean there are, if you want
their money, by all means,
but then you got to take
their notes and stuff.
But you don't have to wait
for somebody to tell you,
"Yes, you may proceed."
You don't have to go out there
with your hand held out and whatnot.
Of course, there's like
Indiegogo, Kickstarter,
you can raise a budget that way
and you're essentially
not begging for money,
you're pre-selling all your
DVDs and whatnot in advance
to help you finance your dream.
But don't get that thinking,
kind of incorrect thinking
out of your head, man.
You don't have to wait or ask somebody
or approach a financier.
I did it on credit cards.
Bunch of credit cards that
I'd kind of put together.
I always feel like...
- Suze Orman is dying somewhere.
- Somewhere, yeah, right?
She's sitting there going,
"I said I was starting my first film."
It's weird, she goes,
"I'm starting my first
film, but I need money."
I'm like, "Well, then you're
not starting your first film,"
or you can start your first film
without needing that money at all.
Some people get blocked.
Everyone gets like a
really good idea of like,
"I want to do something."
Sometimes you sit around, watch
a movie, listen to podcast,
you're like, I want to do that.
Then they stop 'cause they're like,
"I dunno how, I don't have the money."
The money is a hurdle that's
kind of easy to get over,
particularly in the age of technology
where this magical box right here,
or the ones we have in our pockets,
will shoot a movie, you can edit a movie,
you can upload it to YouTube,
all from the same device,
all within like an hour
or something like that.
So, when that technology's at your hands,
sometimes people are a
little afraid about like,
well, I don't know how to use it or,
they say that making movies takes money,
and of course, it does
take a little bit of lucre,
but not as much as like,
that should stop somebody from going out
to finance their own dream or
go out looking for finance.
But that's the thing I try to curb,
don't ask people for money.
If you do that, then you'd
just give yourself an excuse
to never really take the next step
'cause you're like, well,
I couldn't find the budget.
Like, a lot of people
ask me, they're like,
"I was where you were
once, can't you help me?"
And I was like, "Well, the difference was,
"when I was where you were,
never asked anybody for help.
"I just did it myself."
So, it's always better if
you can do it yourself.
You feel better at the end of the day.
And then you're not bugging
anybody with your hand out.
You don't owe anybody.
Nobody's got anything over ya.
And they're also not telling ya, like,
"Hey, you know that vision
"that you've been carrying
around your whole life?
"Change it because there's
something about it that bugs me
"and since I'm shelling out the dough,
"you got to do that sort of thing."
First time out, especially, don't be,
God, my hair looks terrible.
First time out (laughs) especially,
don't go looking for money
from somebody else, man.
Especially that first film of yours,
because you're trying
to get you out there.
The most you you'll
ever have a chance to do
is when you're making
your first flick, man.
If you've got a movie fan,
you've got a movie maker.
Like, I've never met a film maker
that wasn't a movie buff first.
I don't care who it is.
Whether it's like, me,
or great directors like
Scorsese and Quentin Tarantino,
there are hardcore movie
fans who still imbibe.
So, I don't think it's
possible to be a film maker
unless you're a film fan.
So, I always encourage everyone
in those Q&A's where I'm like,
"If you're here listening
to me talk about this stuff,
"you are not a film fan,
you're a film maker,
"you just haven't made a film yet."
Go out and make your film,
because who knows better
how to do this stuff
than the people that consume
it on a regular basis?
And, you know, it's fine, like,
the Internet is a distraction
that allows people
to express themselves
about movies, you know,
and you can be funny and crappy
about, like crap on movies
and stuff, but it pulls
you away from like,
there was no Internet when I
started, so I made a movie.
If the Internet existed,
I probably would've commented
on other people's movies.
But because it didn't exist, I was like,
"Well, let me try to make
one of these movies myself."
And now I live in a world
where people comment on it,
largely I get very wonderful things said,
and then I get a bunch of people
saying crappy things as well.
But none of that exits without
me doing something first.
Without me making something.
So, I always like to
tell that audience, like,
"We're not different, I was you."
I sat there watching other people's stuff
and I just got to a place
where I was like, why them?
Why not me?
Like, if this counts as a movie,
why can't I make a movie and stuff?
Which is funny 'cause that's
what my movies make people do now.
They're like, "If Yoga Hosers
counts, I'm making a movie."
(laughter)
And that's a good call to arms.
I'm not even insulted by that.
I'm like, good, whatever
makes you step forward
and try your self-expression.
'Cause the only reason anyone
knows my name, or my work,
and I've been doing this for 22 years,
I haven't had to get a real job,
is because it started with
a first step of going like,
"Why can't I do that?"
You know, I see people do
it and that's interesting
and I like their stories but
never saw my world represented
up on the screen and that's
where I looked for myself.
I never found myself in a classroom,
I never found myself in a church, man.
Closest moments I've ever
had to finding out who I am,
have been in the art.
Sitting in a movie theater,
watching a movie, man.
It's the dark mirror.
You see yourself reflected in a weird way.
In reading and listening
to music, watching TV,
these were the closest
moments where I was like,
"Oh, I think this is who I
am," and stuff like that.
So that's within everybody.
I've spent 21 years of my
career chasing a better career,
chasing somebody else's career,
because that's all you
have to go by, right?
You look at those who've gone before you.
So my whole career, I've
always aimed for a mark,
and constantly missed it, never hit it.
So by my own standards, very unsuccessful.
But in the process of
doing that for 21 years,
which I believe is three score.
One more score and I'm Gettysburg.
I believe the idea is, over that time,
I established what it is that I do.
In my quest to be somebody
else like John Hughes,
to have the career of a John Hughes,
I wound up having the
career of a Kevin Smith,
which to me is like, eh, whatever.
But, oddly enough, there
are a bunch of people
that are like, "I'll kill
to have your career."
And that's really weird and wonderful.
So any time you get a chance to sit down
and talk to those cats, you
just want to remind them,
"Hey, you can have this career, man."
I backed into and locked
into in a lot of places,
but most of it is just persistence
and willingness to try stupid.
A lot of people don't want to try
things that might not work,
you know what I'm saying?
Everyone wants to to try the sure thing,
and there is no such
thing as the sure thing.
And if you're looking
at somebody else's work
to try to gage your own,
as I have for years,
you will constantly feel like a failure.
Instead, concentrate
on telling your story.
This is the thing I'm real big on.
Your voice is your only
currency in this life,
that's all you got.
Things you see and perceive,
the prism through which
you process all the
information that you take in.
I'd say you're the most unique
supercomputer on the planet,
unique from everybody else.
That perspective is
valuable, insanely valuable,
'cause nobody else can give it but you.
And that's why it's always
better to shoot weird
or shoot different or shoot original
as opposed to shoot what works.
Or go for a successful model
or, as I've tried to do,
try to be John Hughes
or something like that.
You'll never succeed that way.
If you try using your own
voice, you try expressing
your own thoughts that
nobody else could do,
that's your best shot at success,
because that's the thing
that you bring to table
that nobody else could bring.
And if your timing is fantastic,
you say the right thing at the right time,
you could have a career.
So when you get into this business,
they tend to tell you to shape it up,
take off the edges and
make it look like this,
"Hey, that worked, do that."
But all we shoot for that
thing that you want to do.
I remember all of that, and I
remember all the good, though.
That's the important thing.
You can't shake the bad, it's like,
you talk to a hockey player,
they'll tell you every goal they missed,
but they can't remember the ones that they
(coughing drowns out speaker).
You'll remember the that you miss.
And, you know, the
negative sticks with us.
Negative floats right into the surface,
because it kind of allows us
to open a dialog with ourselves
about incredulity, or
maybe I'm not good enough.
It allows you to wallow in
self-esteem issues and whatnot.
We rarely hear the good.
We can't hear the good, we're
not programmed for that.
And I can't tell you how many times people
have said wonderful things to me in print,
in real life, and I couldn't hear it
'cause I'm just listening
to this asshole over here
telling me I'm terrible at my job.
(laughter)
It sticks with you and you
have to train yourself,
and maybe if you're smart
from the job, you realize,
before you even start down the path,
that it doesn't matter what anybody says,
the game's always on your stick.
I'm sorry, it was very tried
and tired hockey metaphor.
(laughter)
That's where I am in my life.
The game is always on your stick
and nobody can take it off
and tell you differently.
There's a dude in the
stands who'll tell you
you're doing it wrong.
They will always tell you that
because critics are people
that know where they're going,
they just don't know how to drive a car.
And so of course they'll
tell you how to drive the car
every step of the way,
but don't listen to that.
And I'm not saying don't
listen to critics (mumbles),
I'm just saying don't listen
to anybody who says you don't,
or anybody that's like, the
negative's going to be there.
Try to lend an ear to the positive.
And that's something that
I've really had to train
and try to do over my lifetime.
I don't know why, I'm just predisposed
to hear and believe negative.
And it's a nice thing
when (audio cuts out)
step up and say beautiful
things about the work you do,
and that's what you got to remember.
Being in a room with this many people
who sit there and groove
on it and kind of,
they want to be there.
We showed this movie
on Sundance first time,
and it was nice, but wasn't like this,
'cause on Sundance, you've
got a lot of interest
and you sit there like this.
(laughter)
- [Woman] Amuse me.
- Exactly.
Who could get through folded arms, man?
(background noise drowns out speaker)
So, you know, you're going
to encounter lots of that,
and sometimes you see it even in Q&A,
it's in the audience, you let
your eyes go some place else,
(audio cuts out) like, 'cause
that's who you're playing to.
And yeah, don't let the...
I'm telling ya, I do regret
how much time I've wasted.
Especially now that I know
I'm finishing, I'm like,
I feel like Schindler at
the end of Schindler's List,
(background noise drowns out
speaker) saved so many lives.
Like, if I had just, in order
to do this did this instead,
concentrated on creating rather
than whining or bitching
or something like that.
I'd have so much more
to show for my career.
But don't let that trap you, man,
don't let saying throw you off
your game, they're going to say.
And, you know what, they're right.
They're absolutely right.
Everything they say, every
horrible thing they say
about your work, they're absolutely right.
They're not lying, that's how they feel.
But make sure you listen
to the other people
who say all the good, who say
exactly what you want to know,
who say exactly what
you're begging to hear,
what you dreamed about hearing
when you wrote that one line
years prior, don't forget to
give them the time of day too.
We spend so much time focusing
on the bitchers and negative people.
Give a lot of attention to
the people that like it,
'cause that's why you're doing
it, that's why you're there.
I'm not going to do what
everybody else does.
I'm just going to do what I want to do,
because life's too short,
and I can't live up
to other people's expectations,
I can only do what I can
deliver in this life.
So I put that on my wrist to remind me
all the time to trust in self.
And, you know, I won't up, and, you know,
(audio cuts out) I made
Cop Out, and Jersey Girl.
You can things up, but
you can learn from that.
There's no such thing as absolute failure,
except sitting there and not trying.
That's absolute failure, but
even if you fail at something,
failure is kind of success training,
'cause you learn how to do
it better the next time.
As long as you try again, you're smarter
than the average bear, some
people kind of try something,
it falls apart, and they walk away.
There's a bunch of cats who, I get it,
they look at it and like, "This is stupid.
"Why would you waste your opportunities,"
or something, they seem to think that
this is something given by others.
They still see it as, you've
been given an opportunity.
No, nobody gave me jack.
I went and created an
opportunity for myself.
Nobody ever shows up at
your door, knocks and says,
"Hey, man, you want to tell stories?
"Here's a bunch of
money, go make pretend."
And that doesn't happen.
You got to make steps toward
that thing, in the first place.
I spend a lot of time
trying to explain to people
the difference between
given an opportunity
and creating your world,
creating your own opportunity,
'cause if you create
your own opportunities,
you're beholden to nobody.
And then people can't say things like,
"You shouldn't do this."
I'm like, "Why?"
So long as I keep my budgets low,
make sure everyone gets
their money back and stuff,
I can do whatever goofy thing I want,
'cause I'll tell you right now,
I don't want to go to my
grave one day being like,
"I should've made the walrus
movies," and then drop dead.
I want to be the guy that's like,
"Can't believe we made that walrus movie,"
and then drop dead, be satisfied.
'Cause we're I'm talking
about reshaping the world
or big important issues, man,
this is all micro, not macro.
It all begins with you.
That's about belief, you can't expect
a bunch of people out there
to believe you are this thing
unless you be this thing yourself.
We shot this flick, it's called Tusk,
it stars this guy, Michael Parks,
who was in this movie Red
State I did three years ago,
Justin Long is the guy,
he turns into a walrus.
And I swear to you, now, this
all came from a dopey podcast
of us going, "Wouldn't it be funny if?"
It's hands down the best
thing I've ever done.
- Seriously?
And the whole...
I'm not lying, dude, I
know I usually say that
on every movie that I've
made, but I mean it.
This movie looks beautiful,
this is the movie
that the guy who made
Clerks dreamed about making.
'Cause I didn't want to make Clerks,
I eventually made Clerks,
but what I wanted to make
was David Lynch movies.
I loved how weird and
wonderful David Lynch was,
but I didn't have enough
talent to do that,
I had enough talent to make Clerks.
20 years later, I have enough
talent to go for the things
that I dreamed about when
I was a nascent beginner.
And part of the reason is
like, all right, up your game,
see how far you could push
it, but the other reason
is I got a lot of people who
listen to me and watch me
and pay attention to the stuff I do.
You got a captive audience, man,
and if you want art in your life,
you want more people
experience what you've had,
and all I did was try.
I had this idea about making a movie
set in a convenience store,
and I tried it, and it worked.
And the life's been blowjobs
and donuts ever since, right?
So you want to encourage
people to do that.
- From one woman, by the way.
- Yeah yeah yeah, not
that Christian girlfriend.
- Yeah.
(audience laughter)
- So you want to encourage
others to do that,
you want others to kind of feel that,
I'm not saying everyone's
got to be film maker,
everyone's got to make TV,
everyone's got to write books, but
why not do a little?
People get in this mindset of like,
"We're the audience and
they're the film makers,
"and we'll watch, and they'll make."
Anybody can do this
crap, I've spent 20 years
trying to tell people like,
"Pick up a camera, it doesn't take much."
Podcast makes it even
more of a great equalizer,
'cause that requires a
cell phone, a laptop,
you sit down with your
friends, your girlfriend,
your boyfriend, your mother.
I've sat down with my
mother and podcasted,
and you just talk.
Anybody could do that,
that doesn't take talent.
But on that podcast, there
were so many people on Twitter
from that episode talking
about, it was really interesting
to hear you guys building the idea.
I didn't know that's how it worked.
And that grabbed me, because
that was me 20 years ago going,
"How, how do I get from here to there?"
And here it was, we'd
lay them out a little bit
on a blueprint on the podcast,
you heard us creating a story,
you heard me going like,
"Yeah, you could do this."
How simple it was, it was just
demystifying the process a little bit.
And you do that as a clarion
call to those out there going,
"Look, hear how simple it is now?"
We showed you how simple
it was once to make Clerks,
black and white movie, pick up a camera,
anybody could do this.
Now with this episode of this podcast
that turned into this movie Tusk,
it's this blueprint for
anybody, for the kid,
for the 13 year old, for the 45 year old,
for the 60 year old mother who's like,
"I always wanted to make a movie."
To just hear how simple it is,
sometimes you just need
somebody to be like,
"It's this simple, dude,"
and give you three steps,
and suddenly you're like, "That's it?
"I can take it the rest of the way."
Getting started is
always the hardest part.
And you got a bunch of
people listening to you,
and it's nice that they're the audience
and I'm glad they're there to support me,
but I want to give it back,
you want to support them,
you want to be like, "As happy
as I am, you can do this too.
"As much as you like watching this,
"making it's even better, go do it."
So this Tusk thing has been
more about the audience,
oddly enough, and not
thinking about my career,
my standing, where I stand
in the film community,
whether I've grown as an artist.
I let go all that stuff, and
all I thought about was like,
I just want to inspire one
kid to pick up a camera
and be like, "If that's
how you make a movie,
"I want to do it too."
I'm just trying to secure my
future, and watch good movies,
and the way to do that is
to show a bunch of people
whose voices are different than anything
you've ever heard before,
not the same thing
you see on TV or movies, to
show them how simple it is,
to show them that their
voice is their currency.
The thing that you have to
say, that special thing,
that story you have to
tell, nobody else can tell.
And you want to encourage
people to do that,
'cause that's all I did, people go,
"Oh, you've been very fortunate and
"what a great career you
had," and the only thing is,
I one day sat there, watched enough movies
and TV to be like, "Why not me?
"They're doing it, what's the difference?"
And it just took a little bit of Slacker,
Richard Linklater from
Slacker, demystify the process.
So for me, with Tusk and this podcast,
the episode that birthed the movie,
and the whole process of the movie
is just a long way of saying,
"Here are your blueprints, go,
"do what I did, because it rocks."
How does one spin so many plates at once?
Well, there's no formula,
and to be honest with you,
it's a very dangerous pastime,
not as dangerous as, say,
juggling chainsaws, but
you tend to get swamped
by your own amount of
projects that you float,
the amount of boats that you float, man,
could come back, turn around like
a Royal Navy and sink your fat ass.
So basically, you got to feel
what's right for you, man.
It helps to have a wonderful
support team around ya,
I have fantastic people in my life,
not the least of which
is that dog, Shecky!
Who make everything I do a lot easier.
I come up with ideas that I want to do,
and other people actually
make it happen, implement it.
So that helps to have a team.
If you don't have a team,
you got to figure out
what that balance is for yourself.
You can't take on too
much, but at the same time,
you don't want to just do one thing.
I like to spin a lot of plates,
because you put all
your eggs in one basket,
don't work out, you're bored,
you've wasted all that time.
But the fact of the
matter is, back in the day
we used to make a movie, and
then work on just the movie
and wait till the movie was out,
and then figure out what to do next.
It would lead sometimes to like,
let's say you made Jersey Girl.
You make the movie over
the course of a while,
it comes out, and then phoom,
that's it, it's over
in a week or two weeks.
So I like to spin as
many plates as possible.
That way like, if this
thing isn't panning out,
or this thing is too
far off in the distance,
or this ain't going to
happen the way I want it.
Boom, we could shift
over to something else.
So that's why I do it, but
when you do, be careful.
You got to find the right balance,
I wish there was a formula to give you.
There's not, it's all up
to you, it's inside of you.
Just to as much as you can
before you get to the point
where like, "I can't take it anymore,"
don't kill yourself for art.
Although if you're going to
kill yourself for anything,
art would be the best reason,
but never kill yourself in this life.
You're ever going to kill
yourself, try being Batman first.
And I go into the emergency room,
and I was like, "Donald Smith?"
And they're like, "I'm sorry, he passed."
And they took me into the room.
There's my father, laying on a gurney.
Just dead, still has
tubes sticking out of him,
they were trying to intubate
him or something like that,
but just motionless, quiet,
no breathing whatsoever.
And it was weird, to say the least,
you always know eventually
your parents are going to go,
but I wasn't ready, I wasn't
ready for that moment.
And then I walked out,
and I went outside and had
a cigarette, I was still a
cigarette smoker in those days.
And I was just thinking
about being half an orphan,
or halfway to being an orphan,
or something like that.
My brother comes out, and I was like,
"Oh, can't believe it, right?"
He goes, "Yeah, it's pretty tough."
And I said, "How was it?"
'Cause my brother was there,
he was staying with my parents.
And Donald, without missing
a beat, my brother goes,
"Dad died screaming."
And I was like, "What?"
And he goes, "Dad died screaming."
I asked, "What do you mean?"
He was like, "Well, he woke up,
"and he was kicking the sheets off
"and screaming about being on fire.
"And he was so hot and so hot,
"and get him water, and screaming.
"The screaming got louder and louder,
"and it reached a fever
pitch, and he died.
"And I don't know how else to say it,
"but dad died screaming."
And that hit me like a Mack truck.
And I remember thinking,
"Oh my god, in this world,
"where even a good man like my old man
"is going to die
screaming, there's no point
"in not trying to achieve
every dream that I have."
This is my eventual
end, one day, that's it.
(applause)
And I really felt like,
"Man, that's like..."
This is my future, we're all probably
going to go out screaming,
so the best thing
to do prior to that is to
try to pack that life with
as much wonderfulness, fun,
productivity, surround yourself
with people that are
going to help you do that.
'Cause in this world,
there's not a lot of support.
There's a lot of negativity,
there's a lot of cynicism.
Even as I sit here and tell that story
about my father dying, I guarantee you
there's a cynical head in
this house, maybe more,
sitting there going, "Who
cares, move on, tell a joke."
The world is full of why, man.
You tell people something,
they'll tell you why.
Throw a rock and you'll
hit somebody with why.
Like, "Hey man, I want to make a movie."
"Why, why do you think you could do that?"
"Why, why, nobody else is doing
it, why are you doing it?"
There's so much why.
You go out and you find why not.
You surround yourself with why not.
People who are just like, "Why not?"
Where you're like, "Hey man,
I'm going to try something."
"Why not, let's give it a shot."
People who try to help you do your dreams,
make your dreams come true,
and you do the same for them,
we're all in this together,
and it costs nothing
to encourage an artist,
that's why I get up here
for almost 20 years now
after the movie, man.
There ain't a lot of film
makers get up after the movie
and spend more time than
the movie itself talking,
but I've been trying to
impart one simple lesson
for nearly 20 years, anybody can do this.
You know what I'm saying?
I wasn't born into a business
or the film business,
or born with a mic in my hands.
I have no discernible
talent whatsoever, man,
I have no connections to the business,
we're from New Jersey and stuff.
I got lucky, somebody picked
up the movie and boom,
I was off and running.
And part of that manifest,
when you're brought into
the indie film community,
part of your job,
part of your honor,
part of your privilege,
is to make sure that keeps
going, to encourage other people.
To tell people it's worth the shot,
just like Wayne Gretzky said,
"You miss 100% of the
shots you never take."
It's always worth the shot.
Now, if you're talking about,
if what your shot is, is you're like,
"I've always wanted to
kill 12 children, Kevin."
Don't take that shot at all.
(audience laughter)
I'm not talking about that, you know,
I'm talking about artsy,
you know, writing a blog,
making some music, making a
movie, making a cupcake store,
a knitting store, putting
together a YouTube clip,
just anything that's
not, "Oh, we must do this
"because it's part of my
job, or this will get money."
Some you just do just to
see if it could be done.
Live a why not life, man, because
we're all going to die
screaming, so make sure,
when you die screaming,
you're totally fulfilled,
you're like, "I took
all the shots, I did it,
"I went after everything I
wanted to, or at least tried."
Take the shot, the shot
is always worth taking.
Whether it's a dopey thing like
podcasting or writing a book
or writing a blog, think about
the encouragement you get,
when you encourage an artist,
think about the potential
that comes out of it.
You tell a dude, "Good job, man."
That person maybe one day writes that blog
that you meme out to the entire world,
'cause it says exactly what
you've always wanted to say,
but couldn't yourself,
or they write that song
that you play over and
over after a loved one dies
'cause it means the world to you,
or they make that movie
that is the one you cling to
when everything is going wrong
in life, oh, you pop that in
and things aren't bad for two hours.
All that comes from encouraging an artist.
Nothing good comes from
discouraging an artist.
So for 20 years I keep
coming up here and going,
"Go out and doing, why
the aren't you doing this,
"it's so fun, you should
do it, take your shot,
"I took my shot and it's
nothing but and donuts."
(audience laughter)
So I'm here to tell you,
man, give it a shot.
Go out and try.
(applause)
- Thank you guys so much for watching,
I made this video because
TheNeckshot asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next, leave it down
in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know, what
did you learn today from Kevin,
what is the lesson that is
most immediately applicable
to your life or to your business?
Leave it down in the comments below,
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally, I wanted to
give a quick shout out
to Gourav Junior, thank you
so much for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word,
and making that funny cartoon
to go alongside it, I
really appreciate it.
So thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you, I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and what your one word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.
- We weren't encouraged to dream, so now,
I'm a standing testimony
to the possibility
of normalcy having everything they want
by simply heading toward it.
I have no talent, no discernible talent,
no abilities and stuff like
that, but I've got will.
I don't have skill, I've been
told that a zillion times
by the critics over and over,
I know that I don't have skill.
But I have will, and will will
take you a lot farther, man.
Everyone in this room is a unique,
powerful content generator.
Out of the million stories to
tell that have not been told,
and they're different than mine,
and hers, and his, and his.
Everybody could do this.
I'm an absolute sham, and I've
done it for 22 years, man.
Anybody could do this, I'm
not saying be the film maker.
Just self-express.
Let 'em know you were here,
tell 'em what's here and here.
We're all in this together and we all
have the answers to each
other's questions and problems.
We just have to relate to one another.
And that this is the way it
is, is to just self-express,
whether it's in social media
or something like that,
which is better from where
you're just saying like,
"This movie sucks."
Tell people some that happened to you,
man, share your story.
I always advocate podcasting.
Podcasting is responsible for
the last two movies I made.
That might scare you away,
don't let it scare you.
Podcasting is for anybody, sit down,
you have the equipment,
it's on your phone.
You sit down, you talk to a friend,
talk to a loved one, talk
to your (audio cuts out).
You send it to iTunes, and
boom, you're a podcaster.
Sit down and record with
people that you love.
We have this weird world where
we know what everybody looks like,
'cause we shove cameras
in each other's faces,
you will never forget what
anybody looks like when they die.
But when people die, first thing you lose
is the sound of their voice, man.
And we don't run around
with tape recorders
recording everybody's voices, so use that,
the decision to self-express,
as a reason to sit down
and record with people who you love,
people who may not be here much longer.
But most importantly, do what you can,
put yourself out there, let everybody know
who you are, man, and share.
I'll get something out of it,
for years, I've loved this.
I promise you, you self-express
in any way, shape or form,
and I'm not saying podcast or movie,
but those are definitely some options,
you get out there and share
who you are with people.
This will happen somewhere
over the course of your life,
this has happened to me multiple times,
and it's been profoundly
moving every time it does.
Go out and talk, just talk, just share,
tell about your life and stuff.
One day, somebody will
come up to you and say,
"Something you said saved my life,"
and they will tell you a long anecdote
about how some throwaway comment you made
made all the difference,
and everyone in this room
can make all the difference
for somebody else, man.
Get out there and (audio
cuts out), and yes,
social media is fine for
tagging around things
and being like, "Oh, take a look at that."
(audience laughter)
But it's also good for a
lot more than that, man.
It's fun to come watch stuff,
it's way more fun to make it.
I implore you all, go out
and be the content generators
you are and tell some stories.
Thanks for being here, everybody.
(applause)